hello i'm alvin welcome back to tasty's
making a big the show where i make giant
food for my friends yesterday i got a
really fun message from my friend victor
who was my very first guest on my very
first episode of making a big where i
made him a giant burger i think he has a
surprise for me so let's go see what he
said
[Music]
yo yo alvin what's good my bro listen uh
my birthday's coming back around and i
was wondering if you might be able to
help me out with a little something last
time for my birthday a couple years back
you hooked it up with a massive version
of my favorite cheeseburger so this year
i want to do things a little bit more
traditional and i was wondering if you
might be able to hook it up with a
massive version of my favorite birthday
cake my favorite birthday cake is for
momofuku milk bar there's no better cake
it's gonna be a little bit of a
challenge but i'm sure if anybody can do
it it's you my bro
okay well vic said he wanted the
momofuku milk bar birthday cake this is
christina tosi's recipe gonna put in a
lot of softened butter brown sugar
shortening if you're not familiar with
momofuku milk bar it is a
fan favorite destination started out in
new york they have a lot of locations
now christina tosi also did an episode
on jeff's table about it and her life
story and it's probably one of my
favorite chef's table episodes
drugs uh
butter sugar shortening and more sugar i
i'm not i'm not drunk i promise this is
gonna cream for a while next up gonna
combine buttermilk which is very
interesting for a cake so grapeseed oil
and clear vanilla extract so this stuff
is not brown it's the the more like
vanilla birthday cake kind of extract
things is actually very important to
give this cake a signature flavor
without making it look too dark little
mix so todd has been working very hard
to make this butter and sugar nice and
fluffy it's like doubled in size so i
think it's ready for some eggs eggs go
in one at a time
that was fun
i like that
four more bloops
i hope you guys are not tired of me
saying bloop
wow look at that texture that's so
fluffy and silky this little buttermilk
oil vanilla mixture gets solely streamed
in get every last drop this looks great
gonna scrape down the sides a bit that's
important it looks like cheesecake
batter they're just like those soft
beautiful luscious ribbons we're gonna
add the flour and in classic making big
fashion alvin is probably gonna spill
quite a lot of this alwyn is going slow
why is alvin talking in third person
alvin doesn't know don't spill alvin
sorry todd i'm hitting his head really
hard
oh wow it only took five episodes but i
don't think i spilled that at all and
then we have baking powder salt and
signature item rainbow sprinkles i don't
want to over mix the batter so i'm going
to take it out i'll get you off
come on get off what the heck dude
oh
there we go this batter is like a cloud
it's so airy and to smooth it out cue
the blue danube waltz
[Music]
that was fun for the final touch more
sprinkles to make it rain this is the
cake batter time to bake this one and
about 20 more of these so we're gonna go
back and bake some cakes
okay while the cake bakes i'm going to
make the frosting we're going to start
with all the fats so two sticks of
softened butter cream cheese i love
cream cheese and shortening all right
everybody become friends okay some salt
some baking soda and a very interesting
ingredient citric acid i'm not a
scientist so i might be wrong but citric
acid is derived from fruits things like
citrus so lemon orange anything that has
that flavor so it adds a really nice
acidity and sourness to this seems
pretty natural and it reacts with the
baking soda so that it kind of makes the
frosting fluffy like the volcano
experiment we did in elementary school
you add baking soda vinegar a small
version of that is happening inside here
so that creates air i think you also be
totally wrong anyways we're gonna move
on here we have some corn syrup or some
of that sheen a lot of clear vanilla
extract and another interesting
ingredient glucose so glucose is another
form of sugar once the sugar changes the
way the things are arranged the texture
changes so it's like this nice glue-like
consistency but i think it adds a nice
texture to this frosting that's cool
well you can't have frosting without a
lot of sugar so i'm going to put in a
lot of sugar i have a strong feeling i'm
going to spill again but we'll see
oh it's out worse worse we're spilling
oh i'm tasting sweet again
oh
it does taste good that's so weird i can
lick a cloud of sugar it's getting so
fluffy it's frosting there's even like
little sugar strings that the mixer just
like caught up that's pretty it's not
definitely not hair but it's like little
icicles of sugar we have a lot of cake
going so a lot of frosting must be made
one of the most interesting things about
the momofuku birthday cake and all their
cakes is that they do a little cake
crumble inside that gives it a nice
really like crunchy texture so i'm gonna
put some flour lots of sugar get out
there sprinkles baking powder salt and
we're gonna mix that a little bit and
then
more of this clear vanilla extract we're
really going through a lot of this
vanilla extract today and then the
vegetable oil just it makes it look
crumbly so the goal is to kind of get
this like a wet sand heavily texture
situation it's almost there kind of
looks like rainbow sand that is done
take this guy out onto the tray spread
them out a little bit and then to kind
of get these like chunks i'm just gonna
like take a handful and like press them
into rough little balls and things like
that so it gets this nice little chunky
texture this is fun it's kind of like
digging for gold but you make your own
gold we have the little cake crumbs of
all shapes and sizes this is gonna go
bake and it's gonna get nice and crumbly
and delicious i use a lot of sugar today
all right so my cake has finished baking
and cooling i'm gonna start cutting out
the shapes we found like a strainer that
was really large macgyvered it ripped
off all of its insides and we're gonna
use this to cut the cake all right let's
go in oh that is soft
oh yeah i didn't bake this in a circle
because i need these sort of clean cut
edges so that's why baking here is the
rule also this is how milk bar does it
they bake rectangles and they cut really
nice pretty circles so i think that's a
great technique some great snacks for
later one cake layer out of many we have
so much cake in the back i'm gonna go
check on that probably cut some more
we're gonna assemble this cake all these
cake scraps i'll combine these with some
milk the way that milk bar makes their
famous cake truffles all this cake's
gotta go somewhere we're gonna make sure
we don't waste any of it
got a lot of cakes this is actually only
half because well we're still making
more back there so i'm going to assemble
the cake as much as i can all right to
start get a nice base going with some
frosting down nice little glue first
layer of cake in and to make sure that
this cake stays as still as we can i'm
going to use acetate strips the same
kind of acetate they use at milk bar to
assemble and stabilize your cake quite
genius really and one thing that milk
bar cakes also have is a little soak so
this is milk with vanilla the same clear
vanilla extract so vanilla milk i think
this helps the cake stay moist i
actually do this with any cake i make i
think this really helps achieve that
nice moist fudgy cake that we all love
very easy salt frosting time as you can
see we have a giant tub of frosting over
here oh yeah that's what i like to see
get this nice and smooth and the cake
crumbs actually go here i like this part
a lot
kind of acts like a structural component
and adds a lot of nice crunch and flavor
pat this down into the cake and more
frosting
now you might be wondering hey albert
that's a lot of frosting and you would
be exactly right but it's victor's
birthday and as you know on the show
it's called making a big not being a
little wuss so we're gonna keep going i
think birthday cakes are less about
maybe the taste of the cake and just the
fact that it's a cake to celebrate but
this cake in itself is a reason to
celebrate if it goes well we'll see
okay layer one done time to keep going
okay next one goes in beautiful more
acetate
come on get down more of this soak this
smells really good more frosting so
apparently after making all this with
the team we're gonna be using over 56
sticks of butter 28 8 ounce cream cheese
packets and 100 cups of powdered sugar
and that's just the frosting i hope
victor is not on a diet
i can already feel the weight turning
this cake has already become a task in
itself all right crumble time
[Music]
we're frosting okay oh we're going for
the bottom of the barrel with this one
all right
that was only two
in it's time for ring number two let's
just say we got a lot of strainers and
dismembered a lot of them we got a tape
to mark how high this cake is gonna be
every mark is like three quarters almost
a foot so we're just gonna slide that in
on over there
i want to take a little break and then
i'm gonna keep building this cake
probably gonna ask for some help i'm
going to need a lot of coffee a lot more
cake a lot more frosting and a lot of
mental fortitude i'll be here for like a
couple hours i'll see you guys in a bit
it's been 12 years i'm now sitting on a
stool my lower back has been crying but
this is the result of hard work
dedication lots of teamwork from the
culinary team and most importantly sugar
every part of my being has been tested
i'm glad this is the finale of the
season because i don't think i could
shoot another episode after this we have
six whole rings on this cake ten cake
rounds two tubs of frosting and the only
thing holding this up besides the rings
are hopes prayers thoughts and dreams
arms and wrists have been pushed their
limit as well speech is slowing vision
is blurring palms or sweaty knees weak
arms are heavy there's frosting on my
apron it's all funfetti a couple of last
strokes to smooth it out and
i'm gonna take a nap
in 30 minutes i'm gonna get this guy
into the freezer to set up he's going to
have to chill overnight and i'll see you
guys tomorrow
it's day two we have the cake out of the
freezer freezing overnight so it's
stable and we also have more cake crumbs
sprinkles and cake truffles that the
culinary team and i made mostly the
culinary team from the cake scraps so
these are actually inspired by the cake
truffles that momofuku milk bar sells
now to the main task i want to try to
get these rings off we have fire don't
try this at home all right here we go
just kind of defrost the sides
all right that should be okay let's get
these rings off oh
first one came off pretty easy let's see
if i can get you off here okay he's
spinning i gotta wedge it physics come
on
oh there it is
two
oh god
this spoon is the best spoon i've ever
seen in my entire life oh oh nope why
are we here
just to suffer
give me a stool
yes it's going i went to the gym
yesterday so i can do this today two
more come on go up higher
rise
why do we fall master bruce i mean
master bruce so we can learn to get back
up that doesn't really apply here but it
reminds me of that movie this is what
like a corset feels like
oh the fourth of that threw me back
oh
one more it's coming up i think
this is a tight fit oh i see the kick is
curving that's why
okay with a lot of help and muscles from
the culinary team we have achieved
woohoo top ring time to peel off this
acetate it's been protecting the cake
the whole time
i'm gonna spend some time smoothing out
the edges the last touch is to do some
vinyl decorating some sprinkles and then
the cake crumbs just gonna put them on
it's victor's birthday so we have a
beautiful candle the art team made in
you go oh this is gonna be oh
it's going in very easily i think this
is it giant version of the cake that vic
requested momofuku milk bar birthday
cake approximately 50 pounds very very
heavy
we did it i'm so tired
this is the actual momofuku milk bar
birthday cake we got one as you can see
there's quite a size discrepancy and our
guest victor welcome to the show again
victor well thank you very much for
having me alvin i'm happy to be back and
i'm very excited for you to see what we
have for your birthday dude i'm super
anxious i cannot wait to turn around
right now and check it out i'll light
the candle for you
one two three
yo
it's like this like the skyscraper of
cakes i can't even talk right now it's
massive holy cow do you want to stay
back there dude no i don't i mean yes
um holy cow i really just want to take
it all in from close you want to come
take it it's gorgeous please please all
right step aside let me get in there oh
man oh and then you hit the mini b oh my
god look at this they snuck the little
mini one in there too people check this
out holy cow alvin i think you really
knocked it out of the park with this one
bro thanks knocking out the park man
everybody
happy birthday
to
you everybody come on
we can't see you right to
you
wow that's always awkward but everybody
thank you very much everybody clap
or make a wish make a wish
[Applause]
i'll cut you a slice please
the knife is being completely engulfed
inside this cake
oh
[Laughter]
i'll give you some more later look at
that here you go victor oh man cake
slice
dude this slice is bigger than the whole
cake
all right cheers man
cheers alvin
whoa
that is phenomenal cool right i think
you've made me the perfect cake alvin
thank you that means a lot i'm i'm so
happy right now i don't know how i'm
going to be able to eat this all but you
better believe i'm going to eat this all
this is slim you really made my birthday
something special this year yeah
what a fun way to close off this season
i hope you guys had a fun time watching
it's a good thing that victor and i both
like this cake because we're going to
spend some time with this cake but thank
you guys for watching thanks for coming
vic and uh we'll see you guys next time
until next time baby
[Music]
[Music]
you